you may have seen a difference you may
not seen a difference but that's that's
pretty much my my new path forward is uh
say less you do more show a bit more um
and if you think well to me it might not
be to you but the class has gone really
quick I know Maps were late but you know
and you've done only two
techniques so um them two techniques
absorbed you and I believe we could have
done them for even longer because you
were starting to understand it get it
get get it and it and it it's got this
sort of gel that starts to happen once
this sort of gel of say Energy starts to
happen you don't know what's making this
feeling come of we could say
satisfaction but it's a feeling of like
just now it's starting to see of flow
you I mean you don't really know how
your body is starting to shave off the
corners of this rough piece of square
wood you know you might understand you
might think I'm not have enough pills or
need more pills but but that's where I'm
trying to now go I'm I'm trying to go
more towards those senses IO than my
master cyto
senses and slowly I'm going to be trying
to show you more yin and yang rather
thano the other teachers hopefully will
still teach the strong Basics but you
can see how important I was showing you
about this small point with the leg and
if you think if you're going to go that
way anyhow so why turn to you know why
turn them that way when you you know
you're not going to about walk over
their body but this way there's an
outlet isn't there if you do that their
arm can slip away from you so by doing
that you've locked the arm or you go I'm
85 I got but you still got Marshal
the